rise of the Tomb Raider is out on pc but  apparently Lara Croft's latest adventure  isn't running as well as it should  fortunately nixes software is fixing  some critical issues with a new patch so  what's the problem well some C++ errors  were preventing copies of the game from  starting sometimes the game wouldn't  properly install which would also stop  the game from booting up and the game  could just crash while opening all three  of these bugs should be squashed now so  you can actually play the game some  additional fixes like more mouse options  and performance tweaks are also packed  into the patch all told this should make  your copy of Tomb Raider run much better  the update should be automatically  applied to steam and Windows Store  versions of the game so make sure you're  running the latest version if Nick's  asst releases more fixes you'll hear  about it from us stick with gamespot and  ray those tombs  you